[Music]
in Fallout cruised dashes through Paris
by car motorcycle and foot at one point
in the scene he jumped from one building
to another and broke his ankle filming
had to be delayed for eight weeks so
crews could recover but his ankle was
still broken during much of filming even
during the movies much talked-about halo
jump scene more on that in a bit
for sequence and rogue nation Cruz held
his breath underwater for at least six
minutes according to the crew Cruz and
his co-star Rebecca Ferguson trained for
this using a program designed for the
military
[Music]
the big-scale highly-publicized stunts
wouldn't truly start for the franchise
until the fourth film Ghost Protocol but
the opening of Mission Impossible 2 gave
us a taste of what was to come in the
sequence ethan hunt on a rare vacation
part takes in some relaxing free solo
rock-climbing though he was wearing a
harness there was no safety net to catch
the star if he were to fall
the first mission movie looks quaint
compared to where this franchise is now
but this high scene well not the most
physically challenging thing Cruz has
ever done is still suspenseful it's the
kind of subtle and thrilling work that
you don't normally see in a mega summer
blockbuster
rogue nation opened with a bang
Ethan Hunt is supposed to board a plane
from a side entrance before its
departure he just misses it
so instead clings on to the side as it
takes off of course crews actually hung
on to a plane in real life no green
screen it was good prep for his big jump
in fallout of course Tom Cruise can fly
a helicopter after months of training he
was ready for the epic helicopter chase
finale in Fallout but first he had to
jump on to a chopper this is a Mission
Impossible movie after all so no way he
was getting on easy according to
director Christopher McQuarrie Cruz
became a certified helicopter pilot in
just three months took a lot of long
days and nights
not only did he fly a helicopter but in
fallout he also jumped out of a flying
plane crews actually did a halo jump a
feat which requires military personnel
to jump from high in the air and then
open their parachutes at a low altitude
so they can sneak into somewhere
undetected crews actually jumps out of
the plane but thanks to CGI the movie
hasn't jumping through a lightning storm
it's a thrilling sequence and it helps
that it's all real they had a very
limited window each day to get the shot
so they wouldn't lose any light at one
point as he was falling he had to slow
himself down to be about three feet from
the camera so the shot would be in focus
too far too close and the shot would be
ruined after a hundred six jumps they
finally got it right
[Music]
in ghost Protocol crews actually jumped
out a window swung around and climbed up
the Burj Khalifa in Dubai the building
the world's tallest towers two thousand
seven hundred twenty two feet in the air
it's a tense thrilling and
anxiety-inducing sequence it's the kind
of thing that reminds you why you go to
the movies in the first place since goes
protocol cruise has gone to even bigger
Heights and service of his fans and yet
will still be hard to top this one heist
[Music]
[Music]